so leadership as a practice I don't
believe that anyone is an expert in
leadership we're all students and some
of us um more advanced students than
others but but it's a it's something
that is ongoing it is literally a
practice and it you have to show up and
try and be a better leader every single
bag yeah and so every leader that I
admire and some of them have achieved
amazing things I mean you're hearing
from some of them today some of them
have achieved amazing things and they're
all curious and when I sit down with
them they all go like this you know and
I and and I'm so enamored by that that
no matter how much they know and how
much they've accomplished they want to
know they know that they there's more to
know I just never know but I mean I'm
talking about the the the you know
Richard Branson Howard Schultz yeah like
all of these guys that I've that I've
had the opportunity to meet they're all
insatiably curious and they all know
that whatever they've done they know
there's so much more they don't know and
the ones I'm suspicious are the ones
that go I think I know what I'm doing I
think no I I'm I'm learning as I'm as
I'm going as we all are and I think the
big mistake that people make about me is
that my organization runs flawlessly it
doesn't it my organization has all the
same problems as every other
organization we make mistakes we have we
make stupid decisions we make short-term
decisions we have we have employee
things the thing that I pride myself on
is how we address those problems that
that we are on the side of patients we
are on the side of empathy and we we
work very very hard to practice the
things that I write about and speak
about but the problems are all the same
yeah it's how we address those problems
that I think is where the practice of
leadership comes in
[Music]